a lot of crazy things happen to our
favorite characters on the loud house
but get ready to watch them as you have
never seen them before
bruiser punch reimagine the loud house
characters and they are stronger than
ever make sure you watch our video until
the end to see what Lorie loud looks
like as a bodybuilder if you love the
loud house as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 loud house characters as bodybuilders
Lily loud at 15 months old she might be
the youngest sister of the family but
that doesn't mean that she is the
weakest when her diaper is full you can
be sure that she is the one who is going
to have the strongest smell and it gets
worse when she takes it off forcing her
siblings to put it back on but don't
underestimate her just because she is a
baby Lily can walk independently and is
already learning how to speak she also
seems to be very aware of what is
happening around her and turns out to be
more intelligent than we can expect from
a one-year-old if she could have one
superpower it would be crying why asked
for what you need when you can use this
annoying habit to get anything you want
but don't worry Willy is usually always
happy so you won't have to hear her
crying too much this baby might not be
like any other but what would she look
like as a bodybuilder as you can see
this is a very muscular baby but there
is one thing that she forgot leg day her
legs are still really tiny compared to
the upper part of her body maybe she
should try to walk around the house a
little bit if she wants the perfect
bodybuilder look Lee so loud who said
that school makes you smarter please
allowed knows that you are never too
young to learn and being passionate
about something is the best way to find
the motivation you need to become a
genius
Lisa is often seen working on
experiments formulas and equations she
might still be in kindergarten but she
is so smart that she could easily skip
at least six grades and if you are not
convinced yet that she is one of the
smartest children you have ever seen she
is also a Nobel Prize recipient but
being too good comes with some
disadvantages as she can be sarcastic
and egocentric with other people if she
could have one superpower it would be
annoying her siblings with her weird
Studies on them just like a mad
scientist usually a child prodigy
wouldn't really be into sports we can't
see Lisa spending a lot of time at the
gym this is why we imagined that she
would take part in an experiment to turn
herself into a bodybuilder without
making any physical efforts and by the
look of it this new invention clearly
works but we are not sure that this new
look suits her if she ever sells her new
creations she won't only win a second
Nobel Prize but will also become a
millionaire who needs the body when you
already got the brain if you want to
watch just one more video the premium is
the platform where you should go get
early access to videos from the things
the taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for free to the premium and get ready
to binge watch videos from your favorite
channels
Lola aloud we think that this child
watched too many princess movies because
she thinks that everything is about
being the most beautiful girl in the
world she loves anything girly including
fashion makeup photoshoots and the color
pink however she didn't learn that you
also have to be kind to meet your prince
charming Lola can sometimes be arrogant
self-centered spoiled and narcissistic
she thinks that she deserves anything
that she wants just because she is the
most beautiful kid in the house the
princess doesn't mind manipulating her
siblings by threatening to tell their
parents all their secrets this is why
she is probably the one who has the most
volatile temper of all the family
members but if you ever want to get rid
of her there is something that you can
always use as a distraction
just give her a mirror and she will look
at herself for hours so what if we told
Lola that being a bodybuilder was the
new trend we bet that she would run
directly to the gym to make sure that
she is the most muscular little girl in
town the more the better
Lola always wants to be prettier and
this bodybuilder look is far from the
princess that we are used to seeing
we prefer Lola as a beauty pageant queen
at least with smaller muscles she is
less intimidating we don't want to see a
bodybuilder with a temper like hers land
allowed if you didn't know that Lola and
Lana are twins it would be almost
impossible to tell these two girls are
the exact opposite it seems like the
princess got all the girly genes and
Lana is everything boyish this young
girl is a tomboy who loves anything that
is not hygienic this is why you can
often find her outside playing with
frogs or digging up chewing gum in the
garbage getting her hands dirty also
means that she is not afraid of helping
around the house and she is actually a
great plumber and no matter how dirty
she looks on the outside Lana is a
beautiful person on the inside always
loving towards her family but if you
ever get on her nerves we bet that she
wouldn't be shy to throw mud at you take
that as a compliment mud is one of the
things that she loves the
most in the world after spending so much
time playing outside we bet that lana
would grow up being very well muscled
she is totally ready for a mud wrestling
competition with her siblings and with a
new body like that we think that she
would easily win but who would have the
courage to get into a playful fight with
her with a bodybuilder look like that we
don't think that we would Lucy aloud
just when you think that you have seen
everyone Lucy suddenly appears out of
nowhere to surprise us and if we ever
compare this to a ghost she would take
it as a compliment
she's the quietest out of all the loud
siblings but probably also one of the
most interesting this goth girl is so
mysterious that we always want to know
more about her we can't even know what
she is feeling because we can barely see
her face always sporting a stoic frown
she even says sigh instead of actually
saying but if you think that she is cold
it's probably because you haven't
watched enough episodes she loves her
siblings and sometimes knows how to take
a break from darkness to have fun with
them anyway we think that she might have
something to hide including her ability
to travel from one place to another with
teleportation this is why her siblings
refer to her as a spooky girl
but what if Lucy was possessed by the
spirit of a bodybuilder we think that it
would make her scarier imagine that
eight-year-old turning into a real-life
monster with that outfit she seems to be
ready to fight in a wrestling match but
we don't think that we'll have to worry
about her too much actually if she ever
becomes super strong she is probably
going to fight evil spirits instead
unless she'd rather be friends with them
Lyn loud here's the girl who would love
to become a bodybuilder but first let us
tell you more about her Lynn loves
turning everything into a sport as you
can see she is very athletic and
competitive name any kind of sport we
already know that she will love it
whether it is football soccer basketball
or baseball even if a sport doesn't
exist yet she will find a way to love it
anyway however her siblings think that
her
for sports can sometimes become really
annoying Lynne always wants to be number
one and they wish there would be more
place for fun she is also prone to
physical confrontations and seems to be
the only one who really loves to fight
however if she has one weakness it is
that she can be superstitious she has to
perform Goodluck rituals and believes
that many things are bad luck but it
seems like everything went well because
she now has the body that she always
wanted Lynne is now a bodybuilder with
the biggest muscles we have ever seen
and she seems to be really happy about
it with this strength she will have what
it takes to be number one in any sports
however we think that she could work on
flexibility gymnastics isn't for her if
she can't even scratch her back because
she is too muscular
luann loud here comes the comedian that
we have been waiting for since the
beginning of this video give her a round
of applause because she is finally here
to make the funniest jokes after all she
needs to practice if she wants to become
a professional comedian and her family
is the best audience we love her puns
even though her siblings think that her
jokes are bad or they are probably just
a little upset because their sister
keeps pulling pranks people believe that
she became narcissistic and cocky after
someone laughed at her joke for the
first time but we think that she
deserves all the attention that she can
get we know that behind this goofy
personality hides a fun-loving girl who
will do anything to make her sisters and
brother smile no matter what happens
LuAnn knows that laughter is the best
medicine this is why she decided to pull
another crazy prank by getting dressed
as a bodybuilder and we think that this
costume is really funny imagine waking
up one day and seeing your sister who is
suddenly really muscular we were
surprised to see this picture and her
siblings would probably be shocked too
we just hope that they will laugh at
this joke because if LuAnn makes all
these efforts she at least deserves to
hear them laugh out loud
luenell loud here comes the girl who is
going to rock your world when she was
younger Luna was trying to find her own
then in seventh grade she went to her
first concert saw the lead singer on
stage and knew that this is what she
wanted to do in her life she took the
stage and knew immediately that the
world of rock and roll was where she was
meant to be since that day she became a
big fan of many rock groups and dreamed
of becoming a rock star this is why she
has been performing non-stop all around
the house singing and playing many
different musical instruments this is
what makes her the loudest sibling of
the loud family and she becomes really
upset when someone turns off her music
no matter what she is one of the most
caring and helping characters in the
family but what would happen if Luna
played guitar so much that she became
muscular like a bodybuilder this is what
happens when you practice every day and
night she might not be able to make a
lot of dance moves but as long as she
can play guitar
this artist is the happiest girl in the
world and we think that if it becomes
her signature look
she will easily stand out in the world
of rock and roll and become a star in
her own right
Lenny loud this young woman is the one
that we would love to have as a best
friend she might not be the smartest
mostly compared to her little sister
Lisa but we don't care at all we have to
admit that it makes her one of the
funniest members of the loud family it
is always ridiculous to see that she
can't walk while chewing gum and doesn't
understand the rules of the games her
siblings want her to play but we can
easily forgive her the best description
of this character is what Lenny lacks in
smarts she makes up for in part no
matter what happens her family will
always be her first priority and she
will be able to face her biggest fears
to protect them and we can't forget that
this girl also has some skills she is
great at designing outfits and
accessories this is why she was probably
unhappy to see that her dress is too
small now that she is a bodybuilder it
is only hiding what needs to be hidden
and we feel like it is going to explode
at any minute
but maybe this will inspire her to
design a collection for body builders
when we see what her sisters look like
in this video we think that a lot of
people will want to buy the clothes that
she does
Laurie loud and last but not least is
the oldest member of the family
Laurie loud it is not easy being a
17-year old when you have to take care
of 10 other siblings this is why she
makes sure that she takes advantage of
her authority and absolute dominance
over them she can be bossy condescending
and has a really bad temper sometimes it
even seems like she is the youngest
child of the family being a grown-up is
difficult and everyone deserves to take
a break sometimes but when it is time to
be responsible we know that she can also
be really protective anyone who grew up
with a big sister knows that Laurie is
no different than anyone else and just
like any other teenagers she is always
using her phone it is her most valuable
object and no one can touch it this is
why we think that if she were a
bodybuilder Laurie would love to take
selfies of her muscular body all day
she is probably sending them to Bobby so
he can tell her that she is the most
beautiful woman in the world and we have
to admit that we would be doing the same
thing if we worked so hard on getting
the perfect body but how much do you
think is too much tell us what you think
about body builders in the comments
section down below and that's it for 10
loud house characters as body builders
for more stories like this don't forget
to watch 10 loud house characters all
grown up thanks for watching
[Music]